on ne construira plus de nouveaux chs
elles vident la coalition venir québec
veut remplacer le modèle d'essai hcd
parce qu'ils appellent des maisons des
aînés des résidences à taille humaine
avec de meilleurs services conviennent
plus histoire de compter le nombre de
belges puis compter le nombre de couches
ont réalisé cet engagement il ya deux
grands défis qui attendent la cac
premier défi trouver la main d'oeuvre le
modèle de la caq propose moins de
patients par maison donc moins
d'économies d'échelle la caq propose
aussi plus de soin des repas adaptés
tout ça ça signifie plus de personnel un
syndicat la csn estime qu'il manque déjà
mais le poste de préposé dans les ch a
cédé prenons juste l'exemple des bains
le gouvernement sortant a débloqué l'an
passé 36 millions de dollars pour
embaucher du personnel
l'argent il est là mais les centres de
soins peine à trouver assez de main
d'oeuvre à 2038 battre tout le monde
aura accès à des services de qualité
avec les nouveaux standards
le deuxième défi de la cac mais c'est de
construire assez de maison des aînés
pour répondre à tous les besoins au
cours des 20 prochaines années il y
apprendre 7500 patients actuellement
dans les sièges sociaux au québec
mais selon le conference board les
besoins vont doubler d'ici 20 ans
considérant que chaque maison des aînés
va accueillir un maximum de 130
personnes et que la caq promet de
construire les 30 premières maisons
d'ici quatre ans eh bien à partir de
2022 ils devront vraiment accélérer le
rythme construire environ 35 maison des
aînés chaque année pour accueillir tout
le monde d'ici 2038
si on se fie aux modèles présentés par
la caq construire toutes ces maisons
devrait coûter environ 20 milliards en
dollars d'aujourd'hui
ceci dit il ya une réalité c'est que la
population vieillit alors que ce soit
d'une façon ou d'une autre il faudra un
jour investir au répondre aux besoins
[Musique]